SHOWED UP TOTAL.
AND WE RECOMMEND THAT.
FOR SIX YEARS, WIKILEAKS FOUNDER
JULIAN ASSANGE HAS LIVED IN THE
ECUADORIAN AREA, BUT SINCE 2016
THAT HAS BEEN TAKEN FROM HIM.
HE HAS A LOT OF ENEMIES OF
COURSE BUT ALSO FRIENDS AND ONE
OF HIS CLOSEST IS ACTRESS AND
MODEL PAMELA ANDERSON.
SHE HAS CALLED IT JULIAN ASSANGE
A HERO AND SAID SHE FEARS FOR
HIS SAFETY.
PAMELA ANDERSON JOINS US TONIGHT
PAMELA ANDERSON JOINS US TONIGH
TONIGHT.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> Tucker: GOOD, THANKS.
HOW DO YOU KNOW HIM?
>> I MET HIM THROUGH VIVIAN
WESTWOOD.
SHE IS A GREAT FRIEND OF MINE
AND A SUPPORTER OF HIS AND SHE
KNEW I WOULD LOVE HIS CAUSE AND
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE GREAT IF I
MET HIM.
AND WE GET ALONG GREAT.
I SEE HIM A LOT, I'VE KNOWN HIM
FOR MANY YEARS NOW.
HE HAS A GREAT TESTAMENT TO THE
HUMAN SPIRIT TO BE IN THE
SITUATION THAT HE'S IN AND TO
HAVE THE FIGHT THAT HE HAS IN
HIM, AND     AND A SENSE OF HUMR
HIM, AND     AND A SENSE OF HUM.
HE IS REALLY AN INCREDIBLE
PERSON.
>> Tucker: IT SO IT RAISES THE
INTERESTING QUESTION, WHY HAS HE
RECEIVED ALMOST NO SUPPORT FROM
THE ENTERTAINMENT WORLD IN
HOLLYWOOD, FOR EXAMPLE?
>> WHILE I THINK THOSE ARE BIG
SUPPORTERS AND PEOPLE HAVE
MISUNDERSTOOD IT, HIS INTENTION
WAS NOT TO GET TRUMP ELECTED, IT
WAS TO GIVE TRUE INFORMATION SO
PEOPLE COULD MAKE EDUCATED
DECISIONS ABOUT THE PEOPLE THEY
WANTED TO VOTE FOR.
SO PEOPLE WANT TO BLAME
SOMEBODY, SO THEY BLAME HIM.
YES.
I GET LOTS OF FLAK FOR THAT TOO
WHEN I'M IN HOLLYWOOD.
>> Tucker: SO THE IDEA IS IF
YOU SUPPORT JULIAN ASSANGE YOU
ARE SOMEHOW AGAINST
HILLARY CLINTON?
>> IN SOME CASES.
>> Tucker: YOU ALSO KNOW
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
REMARKABLY, IMPRESSIVELY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
ALLEGATION THAT THEY WERE
WORKING TOGETHER TO EXPOSE
HILLARY'S EMAILS?
>> THAT'S CRAZY.
EVERYONE LIKES TO BLAME RUSSIA
WHEN ANYTHING GOES WRONG IN
AMERICA AND I HAVE SPOKEN AT THE
KREMLIN MANY TIMES AND THE LAST
TIME I WAS THERE THERE WAS
SOMETHING HAPPENING.
THE FIRST THING THEY SAY TO ME
IS, SO WHAT HAVE WE DONE WRONG
THIS TIME?
IT'S A COMMON JOKE.
AMERICA LIKES TO BLAME THEM FOR
EVERYTHING.
I WAS WITH JULIAN BEFORE THE
ELECTION AND HE HAD NO IDEA, HE
REALLY DID NOT THINK THAT TRUMP
WAS GOING TO WIN THE ELECTION.
BUT, IT TURNED OUT THE WAY THE
DATA.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE SPEAKING
AT THE KREMLIN, YOU'RE HANGING
WITH JULIAN ASSANGE AT THE
ECUADORIAN EMBASSY IN LONDON.
DID YOU EVER ASK YOURSELF, HOW
DID I GET HERE?
THIS IS THE LIFE PATH THAT YOU
PLANNED?
[LAUGHS]
>> Pamela: WELL I'M AN ANIMAL
ACTIVIST, I SPOKE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT, I SPOKE ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND THEY INVITED ME TO
THE KREMLIN, THEY LOVE THE WAY I
WAS SPEAKING.
I TOUCHED A LOT OF PEOPLE AND I
WANTED TO CONTINUE MY WORK IN
RUSSIA.
THAT WAS JUST A COINCIDENCE.
I AM ON THE COUNCIL OF THE
INTERNATIONAL FEDERATION OF
ANIMAL WELFARE.
SO IT IS JUST A COINCIDENCE THAT
I KNOW ALL THESE CRAZY WILD,
INTELLIGENT AND INTERESTING
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU LIVE IN
FRANCE NOW, BUT I THINK YOU HAVE
A HOME IN L.A., MALIBU.
WHEN YOU GO BACK THERE, AND YOU
SAY, I WAS JUST OVER AT THE
KREMLIN TALKING TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHAT KIND OF
RESPONSE OR YOU GET?
>> Pamela: A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
HAPPY ABOUT IT BECAUSE HE'S MADE
A LOT OF GREAT IMPROVEMENTS.
IN MY SITUATION I WANTED HIM TO
STOP PORTING STEEL PRODUCTS TO
RUSSIA AND THAT PRETTY MUCH
STOPPED THE SEAL HUNT IN CANADA,
WHICH WAS MY WAS MY GOAL
INITIALLY.
WE ALSO WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES, AND
ANIMALS IN CAPTIVITY, CAPTURING
DOLPHINS AND WHALES AND NOT
SELLING THEM TO CHINA.
AND ENDANGERED SPECIES.
I'VE BEEN SPEAKING WITH THE
MINISTER OF THE ENVIRONMENT AND
PEOPLE LIKE THAT AND OF COURSE,
THERE'S A LOT OF CROSSOVER
BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT OF CAUSES I
BELIEVE IN.
I BELIEVE IN JUSTICE FOR ALL,
AND JULIAN ASSANGE IS AN
INCREDIBLE PERSON.
IF YOU READ ANYTHING HIS MOTHER
SAYS ABOUT HIM, WHICH IS AN
INTERESTING SOURCE TO GO TO A
COMPANY'S ALWAYS BEEN LIKE THIS
SINCE HE WAS A CHILD.
HE'S BEEN WORRIED ABOUT DOING
THE RIGHT THING AND I THINK IS
VERY BRAVE, AND HE ISN'T REALLY
IN DEEP TROUBLE, I THINK, FOR
HIS HEALTH.
HE'S NEVER BEEN IN THE SUNLIGHT,
FOR SIX YEARS.
THAT'S ALREADY HARMFUL.
NOW HE'S BEEN CUT OFF, NO
INTERNET, NO PHONE CALLS AND NO
VISITORS.
ONE OF HIS ONLY CHOICE IS PRETTY
SOON WILL PROBABLY BE TO LEAVE
THE EMBASSY, AND HE WILL BE
ARRESTED AND THEN DEPORTED TO
AMERICA, WHICH I DON'T THINK
WILL BE FAVORABLE FOR HIM.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
THINK OF ANYTHING OF THIS BUT I